-Happy Friday, everybody.
Guys, the midterm elections
are coming up.
And I saw that by election day,
President Trump will have spoken
at over 30 rallies in 5 weeks.
The media says
that's a lot of time
to spend away
from the White House,
or as White House staffers
put it, "Shut up."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Let him -- Let him play."
Yeah, I read
that Trump is planning
to hold 10 more rallies
before November 6th.
If he gets tired,
they're just going to put a wig
on an air horn
and hope nobody notices.
[ Imitating air horn ]
[ Air horn blows ]
Thank you.
I saw that Trump
actually scheduled a rally
in Florida on Halloween.
He's giving out tickets by
saying it's a live performance
of "The Great Pumpkin."
[ Laughter and applause ]
But the midterms
are just 11 days away.
Yeah, 11 days, or as Trump
calls that, just one Scaramucci.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I read that Democrats are hoping
that their support
for legal weed
will help them at the polls.
I don't know how confident
you can feel
when your strategy relies
on stoners remembering to vote.
It's like, "Is that --
Is that tomorrow?
November 29th, man, I'm there."
[ Laughter ]
"Isn't that Christmas?"
I heard that Utah
might legalize marijuana.
So, a state lawmaker went
to Nevada to research weed.
[ Light laughter ]
When asked what he learned,
his staff said,
"That was four days ago.
He hasn't come back."
He's like, "I'll be right there
November 29th."
As I mentioned,
the midterms are coming up,
and Americans are more divided
than ever about who to vote for.
So we thought, what if we
can combine candidates
to create one candidate
that everyone can agree on?
I'll show you what I mean.
For example, if you combine
Missouri Republican Noga Sachs
with Tennessee Republican
Jody Ball,
they become Ball Sachs.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up, if you combine
California Green Party candidate
Barry Hermanson
with Michigan Democrat
Debbie Dingell,
they become Dingell Barry.
[ Laughter ]
Everyone can relate to these.
If you combine --
[ Laughter ]
If you combine
Illinois Republican Jaye DeBates
and Pennsylvania Republican
Kurt Masser,
they become Masser DeBates.
-Thank you.
♪♪♪♪
-DeBates.
-If you --
[ Laughter ]
Now you're all playing along.
Here we go right now.
Finally, if you combine
Colorado Republican Peter Yu...
-Okay.
-...and Maryland Democrat
Bill Frick,
they become Frick Yu.
I'm just saying, these are all
candidates we can all agree on.
We can all vote for
and come together.
Listen to this.
Did you guys hear
that the Vatican
just launched
a new game for kids
that's like "Pokémon GO" where
you actually collect saints.
-Oh.
-When asked if it's as fun
as "Pokémon GO,"
kids were like, "No."
[ Laughter ]
But it turns out that's not
the only video game
that the Vatican made.
They also released a special
Pope edition of Super Mario.
Check this thing out.
[ Video game music plays ]
Uh-oh.
Oh. Wait.
What?
There's the smoke.
We got a new pope.
There it is.
Fantastic game.
Once can see the smoke, that
means you cleared the level.
-You have a new pope.
-This is going viral, guys.
Someone took a video
of two corgis
working out on a treadmill.
Did you see this?
Two corgi dogs
are working out at a gym.
But I'm not sure they were both
putting in the same amount
of effort.
Watch this.
[ Laughter ]
That dude like...
As long as the Fitbit's
on that paw, it totally counts.
Counts as a step.